bonsoir françois boulot merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france
tout d'abord expliqué nous la démarche
d'avoir signé cette tribune 15 ans après
le non au référendum sur la constitution
européenne la presse n'en parle pas
beaucoup d'ailleurs oui bonsoir alors en
réalité moi je suis signataire de deux
tribunes
aujourd'hui l'une qui portent surtout
sur la souveraineté populaire et lui
donner un véritable contenu et l'autre
qui retrace je dirais l'historique qui a
été le non de 2005 la suite qui a été
réservé à ce nom puisque l'on sait il ya
eu un déni de démocratie même une sortie
de trajectoire démocratique en 2007-2008
quand nicolas sarkozy a fait adopter le
traité de lisbonne et et finalement je
dirais que ces deux initiatives et y en
a eu d'autres d'ailleurs et ont pour
objet de mettre en lumière que depuis
quinze ans on paye encore le prix
en réalité de ce déni de démocratie et
le fait de n'avoir pas respecté la
volonté du peuple qui s'était exprimé
contre le fait de d'adopter une
constitution pour l'europe contre le
fait de faire un saut fédéral et plus
d'intégration dans l'union européenne
parce que finalement ce que les gens
constatent tous les jours c'est que
l'union européenne n'apporterait aucun
bénéfice aux peuples aux peuples des
nations qui la composent et au contraire
ça nous devons à l'union européenne une
constitutionnalisation d'une politique
économique c'est à dire que quoi qu'on
vote droite ou gauche depuis des années
des années nous avons toujours la même
politique et c'est cette politique qui
notamment entraîné la casse des dessins
et suivi qui a commencé par l'hôpital
dont on a vu les effets dévastateurs
pendant la crise du coronavirus alors
vous parlez d'une seconde tribune
effectivement qui s'intitule liberté
j'écris ton nom et noël et dans cette
tribune on peut y lire
ce jour là peut-être que les français
posé la première pierre du monde de
l'après crise est ce que c'est le cas
selon vous j'espère j'espère parce que
en réalité il ya on le voit bien il va y
avoir une concurrence qui s'opèrent sur
le mot souveraineté puisque maintenant
tout le monde s'en réclame y compris
même emmanuel macron est simplement la
question est de savoir quel contenu vous
donner
au mot souveraineté emmanuel macron il
parle de souveraineté européenne
sauf que la souveraineté européenne ça
n'existe pas il n'ya pas de peuple
européen
lorsqu'on dit ça cela signifie qu'il
n'ya pas l'élément essentiel le ciment
si vous voulez qui fait un peuple qui
s'appelle la solidarité
il n'y a pas de solidarité entre le
peuple allemand et le peuple français
il ya donc des possibilités de coopérer
évidemment le peuple allemand n'est pas
notre ennemi mais il n'y a pas de
solidarité jusqu'à présent et bien
l'allemagne qui a une politique de
rigueur et sur le plan budgétaire
et bien ne veut pas payer pour les
français l'allemagne a fait un accroc
dans sa politique de rigueur on l'a vu
en tout cas c'est une idée pour
l'instant mais mais le fait de
mutualiser la dette des pays européens
c'est une nouveauté ça c'est pas de là
c'est pas de la solidarité pour vous
alors la pire chose c'est qu'il faut
voir que ce plan il répond quand même à
la décision de la cour constitionnelle
et constitutionnelle allemande qui a
sévèrement remis en question la
politique monétaire de la banque
centrale européenne cette décision est
intervenue il ya quinze jours trois
semaines et en l'état ce qu'on sait
c'est que potentiellement la cour
constitutionnelle allemande pourrait
retirer la banque centrale allemande du
plan de quantitative easing qui est
opéré par d'autres centrales européennes
ce qui serait quasiment la mort de
l'euro donc on voit que pour rattraper
cette décision du juge allemand qui lui
fait primer les intérêts de la nation
allemande du peuple allemand sur la
construction européenne
angela merkel a effectivement accepté
avec macron de s'engager dans un projet
de mutualisation de l'allaitement
il ya deux choses m'ont à dire là dessus
c'est que d'ores et déjà vous avez les
pays qu'on dit frugaux en fait ce sont
les radars de l'union européenne c'est
en tout cas ce qu'il y a affirme
clairement que ils sont pas là pour
payer les frais engagés par les autres
qui sont sur la défensive et qui ne
veulent d'ores et déjà pas payer en tout
cas les négociations vont être très
difficiles mais après il ya autre chose
la question c'est de savoir à quoi ça
sert de mutualiser la dette parce que si
vous voulez quand vous faites un emprunt
c'est très bien mais vous avez une dette
et comment vous faites
quand vous avez une dette il va bien
falloir la rembourser cette dette et
quant au fait il faut un impôt est donc
la question qui va se poser c'est est ce
qu'on va augmenter la contribution des
états des états au budget de l'union
européenne
asmar il va falloir lever plus d'impôts
ou est ce que c'est la commission
européenne on en parle aussi qui va
créer un impôt mais dans tous les cas
vous voyez que la question en dernière
instance qui va se poser c'est qui va
payer cet impôt supplémentaire et donc
on peut se poser la question est ce que
ce sera enfin les ultra riches qui
paieront ou est-ce que ce seront
toujours les mêmes la classe moyenne et
on se souvient quand même j'espère que
le mouvement des gilets jaunes il est
quand même parti sur la question à taxe
sur les carburants serre que les gens en
avaient marre
et quand je dis les gens c'est un cas
soit yens dans au sens large de payer
autant d'impôts
donc si vous voulez mutualisation des
dettes fort bien mais en définitive la
question sera de savoir as que des états
qui n'étaient pas solidaires jusqu'à
lors accepteront d'être solidaire et
deux dans les pays concernés
l'impôt supplémentaire qui sera prélevé
le sera-t-il sur les ultra-riches enfin
où le sera-t-il comme d'habitude sur la
classe moyenne
est ce que pour vous justement cette
crise-là pouvoir
voir cette transformation des
institutions qui sont compliquées est-ce
que ça va enfin pouvoir s'enclencher une
conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe qui
va aussi être initiés il n'y est
question d'ailleurs d'y faire participer
les citoyens européens ça va dans la
dans la bonne voie selon vous et moi
écouter je crois que la décision de la
cour constitutionnelle mans a été
révélatrice de ce que vous avez des
contradictions d'intérêt qui sont en
réalité deux prisons plus forte au sein
de la zone euro mais également on peut
élargir le prisme au sein de l'union
européenne en général vous avez des
états avec des intérêts contradictoires
vous avez une construction européenne
qui s'est faite sur le dumping fiscal et
social c'est à dire que vous avez des
pays qui se sont spécialisés dans le
domaine fiscal en mettant des taux
d'imposition extrêmement bas pour
certains même je vise notamment
luxembourg conclure des conventions
occultes pour pouvoir attirer les sièges
sociaux des grandes entreprises et donc
ça au détriment de l'ensemble des
partenaires entre guillemets européen
donc vous voyez qu au final même avec
toute la bonne volonté du monde on voit
bien toutes les limites qui sont en
train de se poser et puis après il ya
une question de principe qui est dit
dans les deux tribunes dont on n'a fait
mention au début la question est de
savoir est ce que la souveraineté doit
être incarné par le représentant
politique ou est ce qu'à un moment donné
sur des questions aussi essentielles
c'est le peuple qui doit se prononcer et
moi je considère que compte tenu du déni
de démocratie qui a été celui qu'on a
connu un moment du traité de lisbonne
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus se permettre
un nouveau saut dans le fédéralisme sans
consulter les peuples les donc les
peuples au niveau national donc il va
falloir d'une manière ou d'une autre si
on veut plus d'intégration et bien
consultons le peuple parce que le peuple
doit se prononcer cette question est
absolument centrale et je me réjouis que
désormais et bien on puisse arriver à
essayer de défendre cette notion qu'il
ne soit plus la propriété d'un parti
politique un mouvement de telle ou telle
personnalité
il faut que tout le monde s'empare de
cette idée de souveraineté en lui
donnant un contenu ce contenu c'est
sortir des carcans
du carcan européen des traités européens
parce que ça ne fonctionne plus et il
faut que l'on reprenne si vous voulez
une souveraineté économique qu'on ait à
nouveau les leviers de la monnaie les
leviers du la possibilité de faire une
protectionnisme parce que il n'ya pas
d'autre manière si vous voulez de par
exemple opérer la transition écologique
et relocaliser la production n'y a pas
d'autre manière que de réindustrialiser
le pays et pour ça il faut protéger nos
secteurs stratégiques et donc il n'y a
pas d'autre manière de reprendre ces
leviers souvent et économiques pour
réduire le chômage tout simplement et
donc recréer des emplois et à l'heure où
on a une crise sans précédent celle qui
est économique qui va s'abattre sur sur
le monde en général
eh bien il va falloir que les états et
tous les leviers toutes les manettes en
main pour pouvoir répondre à cette crise
faire de la relance budgétaire s'il faut
faire du protectionnisme
s'il faut et donc est également pourquoi
pas donner des aides d'état aux
entreprises qui en ont besoin
toutes choses qui nous sont interdites
dans le cadre actuel des traités
européens
merci françois boulot d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt france